what I want to do in this video is think
about how we can take the derivative of
an expression that can be viewed as the
product not of two functions but of
three functions and we're going to do it
using what we know the product rule and
the way we can think about it is we can
view this as the product first of two
functions of this function here and then
that function over there and then
separately take the derivative so if we
just take if we just view the standard
product rule it tells us that the
derivative of this thing will be equal
to the derivative of f of X the
derivative of f of X let me close it
with the white bracket times the rest of
the function so times G of X let me
close it with the times G of X times H
of X times G of X times H of X times H
of X plus plus just f of X plus f of X
plus f of X times the derivative of this
thing times the derivative with respect
to X of G of x times H of X G of x times
H of X times H of X let me write that a
little bit neater times H of X but what
is this thing right over here going to
be equal well we can you apply the
product rule again so here I'm just
focusing on this part right over here
the derivative of this is just going to
be G prime of X G prime of x times H of
X times H of X plus plus G of X plus G
of X times the derivative of H times H
prime of X H prime of X so everything
that we had the derivative of G of x
times H of X is this stuff right over
here and so we're going to multiply that
times f of X so let's rewrite all of
this stuff here so this first term right
over here we can rewrite so all this is
going to be equal to F prime of X that's
that right over there times G of X times
H of X
times H of X plus plus and now we're
going to distribute this f of X so it's
f of X times this plus f of X times this
so f of X times this is f of X times G
prime of X the derivative of G G prime
of x times H of X times H of X and then
finally we do that in a white color and
then finally F of x times this is just f
of X is just f of X times G of x times G
of X times H prime of X H prime of X and
this was a pretty neat result this is
essentially we can view this as a
product rule where we have three where
we can have our expression viewed as a
product of three functions now we have
three terms in each of these terms we
take a derivative of one of the
functions and not the other two here we
took the derivative of F here we took
the derivative of G here we took the
derivative of H and you could imagine if
you had the product of four functions
here you would have four terms in each
of them you'd be taking a derivative of
one of the functions if you had n if you
add n functions here then you would have
n terms here and in each of them you
would take the derivative of one of the
function so this is kind of a neat
result